romain tu donnes à daniel vas-y alors
n'attendez
500 euros pour daniel tu les gars de
même pas conne à l'ag vous dire pourquoi
le cacher plus gros que ça je trouve à
temps 500 euros par jour non un bon
cible
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
été par jour m'a pas du parcours caché
de toute façon je vais mettre dix balles
cette barre c'est une journée c'est une
non moi j'avais prévu de l'argent quand
même coin je vais vous dire la misére
aulas a oui parce que je préfère 0 en
réalité mais bon je vous explique t-il
vraiment une langue c'est les personnes
âgées et que c'est important ça a été
créé à l'époque de la canicule et cetera
donc je donne effectivement 1500 euros
aux plus âgés de notre équipe c'est à
dire moi
[Applaudissements]
m
j'ai trouvé
donc là dessus tu verras pocket
je lui donne 60 euros
parce que j'ai envie que daniel bouges
jean-luc daniel sorte j'ai envie que
daniel revivre des sentiments amoureux
et c'est le prix d'une petite visite au
cimetière de montmartre
[Applaudissements]
grand amour sur lequel jean le poulain
alors allez y beau gosse à
vraiment elle les yeux là contre
pas possible sait il seulement même
sanofi d'avoir chauve-souris faire
non mais sans déconner il croit que ça
n'appelle dans la tête à l'envers
tellement ivoirien le gard où 281 3 281
parce que c'est le prix d'un climatiseur
mobile dont je fais la promotion
et ça permettra de refroidir le boisé
aucun
tapage ans et on comprend rien rien rien
rien alors gilles verdez bras 50 euros
pour qu'il peut gagner mais c'est elle
qui menait dois
je supporte pas franchement
elle me saouler à moi qui n'ai aucun
intérêt je la dois ces morts sont je
dois gérer son compte instagram pendant
des heures il ya plein de mecs qui
veulent la paix chaud
d'ailleurs daniel mas daniel qui doit-on
et où toi ta ta ta l'antipode
avancé tu peux citer non non non jamais
le rouge et tout le monde chez
les hommes la pelle ne veut personne
nomme le gars qui était sur son bateau
elle me dit
[Rires]
c'est vrai launay ou larmes en dollars
il espère sans mérite série dire non
ce qui se passait pas vrai mais non je
font tous mes espoirs sur royan je me
dis que son royaume il serait bon moi
je crois que ça arrive aujourd'hui mais
après tout d'autres femmes non thaïlande
qui ont pas en thaïlande et oui malawi
thaïlande savoir plus loin en cours à
radio par exemple à l'ol ait ahmed en
camion lui
et paris mais maintenant
les brosses elle
est alors alors maintenant je vois là
pour l'instant ma mort vraiment mais je
ne désespère pas et vous l'angérien les
boulangers qu'on a vu rien ah oui le
petit j'arrive au jeune rival à ce que
je lis un gardien on avait envie de la
vieille là là c'est un peu trop lasser
attention place à part dans mon sens
un ennemi voulait bien
[Applaudissements]
faire à quelqu'un qui
à 9,1
ouvert mon père je peux appeler monde at
il d'abord des
seuls la génération klm serait pour toi
j'avais une idée après votre père
j'appelle ma mère si oui s'appelle
mariage et moi c'est l'aquarelle c'est
mieux ouais j'y vois c'est là paraît
court daniel ce que ma mère elle a
trouvé des mecs à beaucoup de monde
ouais mais bon on fait des matches comme
ça ouais compter d'appel là j'appelle ma
mère t'inquiète pas je vais trouver un
mec toi oui c'est sûr elle
cherchait pas la deuxième sonnerie je
rappelle que madame hanoune à jour la
navette 1250 tonnes
troisième sonnerie en plus le pire c'est
qu'elle me regarde c'est à dire qu'il
veut vraiment pas répondu
ces gens ces jours
ça y est
deux chars
des champions même elle elle se dit
l'accident d'une galère à
berne va mettre dans un bourbier c'est
pas bon là franchement là m il va mettre
dans une sauce là c'est pas bon
franchement je suis passé d'un âge
savoir qu'elle va me rappeler peut-être
que mon père faisait vomir
vous avez un bon père bon sens mais oui
vous m'avez dit que mais bon non mais là
je vais pas je peux pas attention la
meilleure depuis votre mère me fait un
petit peu peur
avec moi même ma mère tu peux prendre un
mot la wii alors
alors
soyez aimable aussi oui alors
c'est qui
les chalands tel torontois drake qui
m'appelle je suis allé défoncer le maire
alors on sera menée au collège et pathos
ference pas reconnu j'entends rien ah
oui pis c'est pas de moi de ma mère
moi ce maillot passion thaïlandais ce
problème
un problème je vous donnais des
problèmes baker bodmer vous appelle sait
pas marquer maman et mariée quoi comme
numéro masqué nom
numéro de mer
ce genre de la nuit votre nuque et à
ma mère me rappelle pas du tout
l'échéance est en train de casser on en
est et où lé avec l'argent là alors
daniel mann
entité sera doté de trois enfants avait
des gens thaïlande match assez d'être on
trouve beaucoup six mois pour daniel 10
euros pourquoi les héros parce que je
savais bah voilà non ça n
va dit qu'enfin mois pour daniel 10
euros 10 euros parce que je peux pas
plus mais avec 10 euros tu vas aller à
harare gare d'argenteuil tu vas prendre
le train de 21h45 qui va t'emmener à
cergy-pontoise là bas tu descends tu as
les aires de repos pour les routiers sur
l'a15
[Applaudissements]
à
moi pas
[Applaudissements]
38 et je peux te dire tu vas tu vas
trouver l'amour là bas
bien du scania du volvo
[Rires]
moi je mets le paquet pour daniel g les
tice en six ans parce que j'estime qu'il
faut qu'elle ait un relooking extrême et
moi j'en ai marre de ces colliers
coquillages tout petit moi je veux
dusautoir je veux dire à ce point ouais
je des pendentifs sur son décolleté je
veux des grosses boucles d'oreilles des
branches animalière je fais un truc un
peu spectaculaire ce soir c'est pas un
peu trop
décroisée comme ça il faut vraiment se
réinventer voilà alors que je vois la
rédaction
je m'appelle 600 km
120 alors qu'est ce que vous dites là
600 euros sans déconner et vous savez
que vos connu on dirait les colis qu'on
a pour la fête des mères des
appareils auxquels on
obtient la joie c'est vrai toit limite
faute de quoi
un méchoui mois 75 euros j'ai décidé
d'enquêter pour savoir puisque valait
réellement daniel sur le marché sur
lequel je me suis déguisé en daniel
moreau et je me suis rendu au coeur du
bois de boulogne
c'est
mais touchés tu sais qu'elle est
excitante
a duré trois heures j'ai rencontré
quelques conducteurs zégarés dont
bernard le roux chick lembras j'ai
récolté 75 euros mort d'anna malromé va
très bien merci laban alimentaire comme
ça lui irait bien des comptes il est
vraiment
très moche et 315 euros ça laissait pas
vraiment bien j'ai bien de serre à 115
et invités côté très belle
prenez-vous si
c'est bon direct voilà lé potable
selon m conte mais qu'en fait ce n'est
pas vrai tout cas vous avez le don de me
désole
et le don de faire des compliments